he just loved this game he just looked
is what
that was that voice notice injury he's
with Emily but he was also just with
Chris and Ashley so maybe that okay I
mentioned this to to you earlier today
we were discussing it that that really
did look like I was dying but she does
make a comment that was like maybe we
should check to see if it was really him
or he was really dead then they were to
go with it because it's really key so I
yeah it occurred to me maybe Josh isn't
actually dead because there was part
Ilia where he high-fived Sam no he
wanted to and then Sam didn't and it
said butterfly effect update and why
would that have happened because that
affected Sandy Josh's relationship
didn't they haven't seen each other once
since why would it affect their
relationship if if he wasn't ever gonna
see her again
so I thought that's a long shot they
don't we go back to the show
you'd do it I don't know how to get that
if you're feeling that way dunno I think
they've walk don't run I don't think
we're allowed to ha ha
wait stepped forward you know from all
the time whether it's awesome Ellen
they're still up no no I mean I don't
think that bad Nia where do you think
that's probably what it is where else I
can go to check it but yeah so the fact
that she just said that I mean you know
I'm pretty sure Jeff is dead because
they look really good it's just that I
was so convinced he was the bad girl to
give these things up yeah you did you
like his actual I was just so convinced
the dead 9 and cable car which is great
where's everyone else though
to leave the side you got a mountain
which is great I'm sure it but horribly
wrong
yeah try to go somewhere all right have
an exhale good stuff
you know know that I was like oh I can
control everything
hope in this way yeah he control tivity
see I would have gone with smash door
just because I figure if he wanted to
get up again it doesn't matter who
didn't see where they always it's it's
true you know what yeah yeah because at
least only one it the other way together
yeah if he wanted to go and get them I
might be just sending it to a disc yeah
which one I'd target he's got a good
night just yeah why are you worried
about because yeah if you don't wanted
to be where they are right now
he's just sitting in front of his
cameras watching he knows what's good
he'd be running if he wanted me this is
wearing me
ah
we went undercover is the faculty just
that they made anything plural which I
guess is always option with the wristlet
or two parts on it wouldn't let me move
too much
we're going to have the chain
we're in paintable very friendly
okay
and we control again children not only
can I control
so he's gone
okay let's do it yeah yeah yeah
but okay it did say names where there's
not once
let's say about Matt honest charming
funny Braverman curious it doesn't say
he s mama but we did say that at a
previous time yeah it was Emily and that
I think I remember that much m-michael
yes sir and much that's I mean
try not just get you down
no gonna walk away - Jenny look at the
chairs up it hill yeah I don't know
maybe it's the only way to go we select
other that other guy up man that'd be
yeah must be the only way to go which is
weird
poof
sorry I'm on again okay shiny battery
now to be super mad family minutes no
the trek I feel like just hunting boys
mad so it doesn't make a huge difference
now
that's cool the way they were in that
corner with it but that I leaned into it
likes a new antennas it was shaped like
that yeah yeah okay
let's go Justin
well I'm glad it has Max and Max
Pentagon and shady people getting
equipped to deal with whatever shits
going down on water [ __ ] or longstreet
it this way the way they write down to
go up
well the they have got away can I just
speak to them they have no other option
no I'm good because he shut the gate on
the other way that makes me hate it
I think they should be Clio is I agree
man yeah I'm she's more fun
but at least wait student launch
careful yeah I don't know he expects to
be honest but you know the guy who's
engineering else yes I think he's
engineering the killer yeah yeah and
that that he's a big whatever killers
imagination I think that they were
thought that yeah
you see last
instead the cat yeah totally
let's have a look white Vincent watching
it's fish scaling inside the house
Washington let's first open the door
again a house with Ashley
look stop country it's pretty big that's
how the wounds wrap
or inside school yeah no doubt actually
it was a pretty dumb thing to say yeah
what's your stuff yeah like what did it
go the noise it was the first one that's
that joining thing that it
what's that hell he is crazy he is elk
crazy elk they are
Wow that's